[Applaudissements]
10 septembre dernier vous le savez il
est devenu chef conservateur il a en
fait balayé tout sur son passage une
victoire
décisive et ensuite disons pierre
pollièvre bonsoir à vous merci ensuite
disons vous a moins vu disons ça comme
ça est-ce que vous aviez besoin d'aller
réfléchir plus seul on vous a moins vu à
peu près pas d'entrevue pas de pas de
grande tournée pourquoi mais j'ai eu
l'occasion d'écouter les gens de
d'écouter leurs histoires je voulais
vraiment savoir
l'état de la vie des Canadiens et ce que
j'ai entendu c'est que peu importe
combien les gens travaillent fort ils
s'avancent pas après l'inflation ce qui
est le plus élevé en 40 ans et les
impôts qui augmentent les gens ont le
sentiment de ne pas pouvoir s'avancer il
y a des jeunes qui vivent dans le
sous-sol de leurs parents à cause des
prix des maisons et maintenant les prix
des taux intérêts il y a des maires
monoparentales qui doivent mettre de
l'eau dans leur lait de leurs enfants
parce que c'est trop coûteux d'acheter
des épiceries et je suis en train de
partager mon idée c'est que il faut
contrôler les dépenses du gouvernement
pour réduire l'inflation que le
gouvernement du trou doit causer il faut
réformer les impôts et les programmes
pour que le travail devient payant
encore il faut éliminer la paperasserie
pour pouvoir produire davantage
d'énergie et de technologie verte ce qui
va alimenter notre économie à l'avenir
et vous dites et en campagne pour
devenir chef et ensuite vous dites les
Canadiens sont en colère contre du saint
Trudeau contenu de l'inflation qui l'a
en partie provoqué dites-vous depuis le
début or l'élection partielle dans la
région Toronto comment ça se fait qu'on
a pas senti la colère des Canadiens mais
premièrement j'ai dit que c'est la peine
les Canadiens les Canadiens sont en
train de souffrir et c'est pas moi qui
dit que juste intruder alimente
l'inflation c'est le gouverneur de la
Banque du Canada c'est son ancien
ministre des Finances Bill morno qui dit
que trou d'eau a trop dépensé écouter
quand on on a 500 milliards de dollars
de déficits ça va ajouter à l'inflation
ça augmente le prix de des biens qu'on
achète l'intérêt qu'on paye et ça rentre
la vie impossible pour certains il y a
un point 5 millions qui vont un une
banque alimentaire il y a le une des
banques alimentaires a dit que certains
de ses membres avaient cherché l'aide
d'un médical à mourir pourquoi parce que
c'est misérables des pauvres et c'est ça
le pays après 7 ans de juste un trou
d'eau les gens ne peuvent pas payer les
factures mais je comprends tout ça mais
ma question c'est comment se fait-il
vous n'avez pas réussi vous à traduire
ça dans un meilleur résultat électoral
dans la région de Toronto parce que si
vous arrivez pas à gagner dans la région
de Toronto vous serez jamais Premier
ministre mais on va gagner à Toronto et
on va continuer de partager un message
ce quand je rencontre des jeunes à
Toronto je vois les jeunes qui ne
peuvent pas m'acheter une maison pas
simplement parce que les prix ont doublé
sous Justin Trudeau mais parce que selon
encore le gouverneur de la Banque du
Canada les déficits ajoute au taux aux
augmentations de taux d'intérêt ce qui
rend sa plus difficile pour les gens qui
ont déjà des hypothèques mais juste et
moi mais moi je sais que vous vous
voulez parler des affaires politiques
moi je parle des ceux qui touchent
monsieur et madame tout le monde
ma responsabilité pourquoi Monsieur et
madame tout le monde un mécesseur n'ont
pas davantage voté pour votre partie
c'est un peu sur ma question mais il y a
eu un ancien ministre et finance qui
s'est présenté pour le Parti libéral
mais c'est correct mais on va gagner des
prochaines sélections en rendant la vie
meilleure en faisant en sorte que c'est
possible de s'avancer avec le travail je
vais rendre le travail plus payant on va
combattre l'inflation et on va permettre
nos entreprises
toucher les gens avec des meilleurs
chèques de PC ça mes priorités la
priorité de beaucoup de Canadiens de
beaucoup de Québécois c'est la santé
vous suivez l'ajout de ping-pong entre
les provinces et le gouvernement fédéral
on a l'impression que ça tourne en rond
puis que les choses aboutissent pas
est-ce que vous vous donneriez l'argent
province sans condition mais moi
j'aurais des bus très clair trois buts
réduire les listes d'attente davantage
de médecins et infirmières et
d'approbation fédérale des médicaments
et de traitement ça c'est fédéral et
c'est trop lente maintenant il y a
beaucoup de traitement et médicaments
qui sont disponibles qui fonctionnent
très bien aux Etats-Unis en Europe qui
ne sont pas disponibles aussi parce que
le biocratie au Canada c'est trop lent
alors c'est celle sur trois priorités
que j'ai poursuivre en termes de
médecins et infirmières j'ai une
proposition très concrète et pas coûteux
c'est de permettre nos immigrants qui
sont médecins aux infirmières de
travailler dans le système selon un
système esthétique Canada 43% des
médecins immigrants et des 37% des
infirmières immigrants travaillent dans
le système les autres sont effectivement
bannis moi je veux signer des enfants
avec les provinces pour accélérer leur
reconnaissance et permettre ces médecins
et informés de travailler pour aller
chez les citoyens mais pour les
transferts d'argent ou provinces est-ce
que comme Monsieur Trudeau vous
demanderiez que des indicateurs communs
qu'on puisse voir qu'est-ce qui marche
qu'est-ce qui marche mais premièrement
que vous parlez des indicateurs je
trouve ça incroyable que juste un trou
d'eau a réussi à doubler le dette
nationale ajouter plus de dettes que
tous les autres premiers ministres
ensemble dans notre histoire sans
améliorer notre système de santé et
enfin c'est pire que jamais après 7 ans
de Justin Trudeau alors je vais
m'assurer que tous les dépenses
obtenir obtiennent des résultats pour
les Canadiens moins de liste d'attente
plus d'infirmière et des médicaments et
traitements plus avancés plus vite
est-ce qu'on est au Canada selon vous
pour qu'on revoit la Loi canadienne sur
la santé pour dogford fait une place un
peu plus grande au privé c'est annoncé
dans les derniers jours pour des
chirurgies pour réduire les listes
d'attente est-ce qu'on doit réécrire la
Loi canadienne sur la santé mais moi je
crois que les principes dans la Loi sur
la santé sans banque on veut que les
Canadiens et la santé sont devoir payer
son changement
c'est pas une question de ça c'est une
question de l'assurance
devrait payer le prix pour tous les
essentiels dans le système les provinces
peuvent travailler pour le rendre plus
vert plus efficace plus vite pour
ajouter davantage de médecins et des
infirmière mais le principe que tous les
Canadiens devraient pouvoir recevoir les
services sans devoir payer c'est un bon
principe qui est dans la loi honnêtement
je vois aucun Premier ministre au Canada
qui est contre ce principe donc
l'univers société vous y touchez pas il
y a pas question non il y a pas des
provinces qui poursuivent un changement
de l'université à ce que je vois les
Canadiens ont eu de la difficulté avec
le gouvernement fédéral dans les
passeports il y a des délais énormes
aussi pour les immigrants pour les
réfugiés qui attendent deux ans deux ans
et demi avant comment vous faites-vous
pour que les citoyens aient des
meilleurs services mais c'est incroyable
on a un gouvernement qui coûte plus cher
qui a doublé le détentionnel qui dépense
plus que jamais et on peut pas obtenir
une passeport il y a un point un million
des migrants qui attend plus lent que
que le standard il y a des aéroports et
des fois et c'est ça c'est sept ans de
Justin Trudeau ok qu'est-ce qu'on fait
il faut demander aux fonctionnaires une
performance il faut que les ministres
soient concentrés sur des reverrai
résultat et non pas sur simplement de
dépenser pour rien donc moi je mettrai
en place des mesures de résultats et je
demanderai fonctionnaires et au système
de livrer ces résultats parce qu'on n'a
jamais eu ces gens de problèmes quand le
gouvernement concevateur était en place
on n'avait pas des grands problèmes pour
obtenir un passeport on n'avait pas ces
gens de liste d'attente
sous les conservateurs libéraux c'est
aussi les limitée et mais en même temps
la réalité c'est on peut on était
capable de livrer les services parce
qu'on se concentrait sur les services de
base et un gouvernement fédéral qui fait
moins qui se concentre sur des
responsabilités de base au lieu
d'essayer de faire tout sera beaucoup
mieux à livrer pour les contribuables
tourner au Québec vous êtes les sondages
le montrent vous allez me dire on a du
temps pour les sondages mais les
sondages le monde vous êtes moins
populaire au Québec quel est votre
objectif est-ce que vous vous voulez
proposer au Québécois en plus que sur un
peu a fait ou d'autres ont fait c'est à
dire par exemple je n'interviendrai pas
pour la loi 96 je vais vous donner un
statut quel est votre op pour séduire
les Québécois mais je respecte le
l'autonomie du Québec je veux pas
m'ingérer dans leur décision je les
Québécois sont capables d'être maître
chez eux comme on dit en plus je pense
que les Québécois ont les mêmes
préoccupations que les autres Canadiens
lesquels les Québécois travaillent plus
fort pour perdre ça au taxes aux impôts
et à l'inflation je suis le seul chef
avec un plan de limiter les dépenses et
le coût du gouvernement du fédéral avec
une loi qui oblige le gouvernement
trouver un dollars d'économies pour
chaque nouveau dans l'ordre de dépenses
éliminer les gaspillage et les contrats
exorbitants pour les
entreprises libérales et aussi réformer
le système de taxes et d'impôts pour que
sur le travail devient payant encore les
gens veulent s'avancer mais les gens me
disent peu importe combien je travaille
je fais pas d'avance parce que le
système est brisé moi je vais leur
permettre de s'avancer avec le bon
travail pour des questions d'actualité
monsieur poirievre monsieur Zelinski
demande des chars le Canada a 80 à peu
près léopard 2 est-ce qu'on doit envoyer
les chars canadiens en Ukraine je ferai
une étude là dessus je suis ouvert
évidemment il faut appuyer les
ukaniens contre l'invasion mais au même
en même temps il faut regarder notre
militaire étant mauvais état le mauvais
gestion de Justin Trudeau et le
sous-financement a laissé notre
militaire dans une mauvaise situation
qui n'est pas prêt donc il faut regarder
ce qu'on a pour aider
votre prédécesseur dit dans un papier on
a beaucoup posé des questions Ottawa
là-dessus a dit la politique au Canada
est devenue trop divisible trop
agressive trop de rage trop de colère il
a dit on a dit une responsabilité les
élus vous avez une responsabilité
à faire baisser le ton êtes-vous
d'accord avec ça monsieur polaire parce
que excusez moi pendant la campagne au
lit de Chypre l'équipe Charest vous
l'avez pas simplement balayé là vous
avez tiré à boulet rouge non j'accepte
pas cette description de réalité c'est
que le pays oui c'est vrai que le pays
est plus divisé que jamais et c'est qui
dirige le pays c'est juste un trou d'eau
depuis 7 ans c'est lui qui est
délibérément divisé les gens et la 5000
à part comme outil politique ça n'a pas
fonctionné ce que je dis je partage le
peine et le souffrance des Canadiens
c'est pas entre ignorant leur souffrance
qui vont devenir plus heureux non c'est
en leur donnant de l'espoir que les
choses peuvent s'améliorer et c'est ce
que je fais j'offre l'espoir au Canadien
les raisons pour lequel les gens voté
pour moi dans la course à la chefferie
oui ils sont fâchés mais ils sont en
peine mais j'ai je leur ai offert de
l'espoir l'espoir que le travail peuvent
devenir plus puissant encore à payer
encore que les gens qui puissent se
reprendre le contrôle de leur vie et
c'est en donnant de l'espoir aux gens
qui vont on veut devenir on va devenir
un pays plus uni donné de l'espoir aux
gens oui d'accord mais aussi ne pas
mettre de l'huile sur le feu comme on
dit de pas mettre de l'essence quand ça
brûle de pas avoir un discours tellement
agressif ça est-ce que vous en prenez
une partie en disant c'est vrai qu'il
faut la classe politique en général on
doit faire attention vous vous
connaissez monsieur poignet oui je le
connais et très bien mais je regarde de
façon dont le premier ministre des vise
et je pense que oui il faut reconnaître
soit la peine que souffre les gens c'est
dur la vie est maintenant quand on quand
les gens doivent aller à une banque
alimentaire pour demander et l'aide à
mourir médical quand parce que on est
malade mais parce que on est trop pauvre
ça c'est un vrai souffrance il faut
reconnaître que les Canadiens souffrent
beaucoup plus que jamais dans ma vie et
aussi leur donner de l'espoir que ça
peut améliorer et c'est l'espoir que
j'offre aux gens maintenant pierre
poillien aura bientôt parce que vous
avez renoué avec les médias vous allez
faire des entrevues maintenant j'ai
jamais arrêté mais quand même
juste les médias au collines
parlementaires je pars à tout le monde
parce que moi moi je partage le vent les
voix de tous les Canadiens pas juste le
tribune parlementaire très bien pierre
pollièvre a bientôt merci beaucoup au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI